[Music]
hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today we're gonna be
continuing our series and general chess
strategies that i just think everyone
should know in a chess game first video
we we talked about opening close games
as far as pawn structure and how to play
accordingly and how to recognize that
very quickly and today we're going to be
going over a pretty important concept
which is bad bishops first good bishops
and we're gonna be talking about how to
notice which bishops are good and bad
pretty quickly and then how to play
accordingly in your game this is
something that every player should be
aware of and if you're not this could be
a very informative video for you so one
of the first things you want to look at
and we'll look at white in this
situation we'll look at the bishop on
the dark square and you want to look at
where the pawns are and so if you look
at blacks pawns highlighted in green
here they're on the dark squares as well
and so whites Bishop has targets on the
dark square and you can tell on the
light squares white is not hindered and
blocked in by his own pawns and that's
what you want in this case White's
Bishop is a good Bishop because he has
targets and he's not blocked in on the
flipside if you look at black you can
tell that his pieces are on the same
colored square he's a dark square Bishop
here on b6 and he's blocked in and why
White has his pawns on the light squares
so if you look at this
black cannot touch any of whites pieces
and the king can stay on light squares
the entire game and this Bishop is at
the moment completely useless and white
has lots of different targets here he
has all three of these different pawns
that he can attack so in this scenario
it's pretty easy to look at there's not
a lot of different pieces on the board
but in this scenario it's very easy to
see that's why I use this illustration
which Bishop is good and which one is
bad in this case the white Bishop is
good because it has targets and its own
pawns are not blocking itself in so this
is the first example that we'll look at
now let's take a look at a different
example and look with a few more pieces
on the board and take a minute and just
think about who has the good Bishop and
who has the bad Bishop now everyone may
not have a good and another may have a
bad but it is good to see so in this
example take a minute you can pause if
you want but see which side you think
has a good Bishop in which one has a bad
Bishop and hopefully you guys came up
that black has the good bishop
as you can see blacks pawns are not
restricting the movement all blacks
pawns are on light squares and the black
pawn or the excuse me the black Bishop
can move around freely and he has
targets on the on white side and white
can't move anywhere because he's blocked
in by his own pawns and he has no
targets from the black pawns on the
light squares so hopefully y'all saw on
this example that black have a good
Bishop and white had the bad bishop now
let's look at this in a another chess
example and see how we can practically
use it
so that we can move out of this and try
to exploit the good and bad bishops for
each side go ahead and look at this
situation it's blacks move think about
some of the key concepts that we've
covered so far as far as what makes a
good bishop what makes a bad bishop and
take a minute you can pause the video if
you'd like and try to think about what
Black's next move should be and
hopefully you came up with the simple
move Bishop to g4 as you can tell
looking Black's LightSquared bishop is a
bad bishop it's blocked in by its own
pawns on light squares and it doesn't
have targets and whites LightSquared
bishop is a good Bishop it's not blocked
in by its own pawns and it has targets
from black on the light squares so black
has a bad bishop white has a good Bishop
and we're trying to trade this off as
you can tell white has nowhere to
retreat if he moves along this diagonal
he'll be taken by pawns if he stays here
obviously we're just gonna take in
exchange the only thing he can do is
capture or be captured if he does
capture we have our queen there to just
recapture and it's these subtle things
if you look at it someone that doesn't
know much about good bishops and bad
bishops may say well you know they
traded equal material but it's the
subtle things like this where we trained
it a bad Bishop for whites good bishop
that many times can control the fate of
a game so always keep these these little
nuances in your mind when you're playing
a chess game this video is obviously not
too long but I did want to cover a very
key concept good and bad bishops so
anytime they're in your game always be
aware of good and bad bishops be aware
if you're looking to exchange yourself
that you're not giving up a good Bishop
for a piece of
equal or lesser value that may not be
playing as an important role just these
small things that we're gonna be going
over in these videos is gonna really
help you guys out a lot in your chess
game so hope you guys enjoyed part two
got a lot more good stuff that's going
to be coming out if you haven't already
please subscribe helps out a lot and I
got a lot of new videos coming out so
you'll you'll know exactly when they do
come out also if you haven't checked out
the website it's up and running got some
pretty cool stuff on there that I update
daily it's just the chess website calm
pretty easy also if you guys would just
leave me comments let me know how it's
going obviously trying to make this one
of the best channels for you guys to
learn and enjoy so just let me know how
I'm doing and other than that I will see
you guys next video thanks a lot for
watching